welcome to this video against Alex from
Germany he's always playing Bishop f4 so
I'm trying to do something against
Bishop f4 playing an entire London set
up here which are just invented okay so
he is really taking the center okay
that's of course a good good a good
setup occupying the center haha so he's
he does not really want to give up the
idea of this Bishop development okay
maybe here to get some some development
going well yeah okay white is certainly
better here what Quincy seven was more
of a joke move trying to prevent the
Bishop f4 business but ok black it's not
in a terrible shape here it's fairly
solid ok probably just Castle v5 I can
take it's not not so dangerous i believe
yes night f4 here okay here okay let's
do that it's a bit a bit risky but still
interesting using their file that's a
very important point that the rook is
controlling the fourth-ranked okay so he
wants to take here but I have Quincy 6
on that so we cannot really take him oh
right now an idea for is covering g2
okay for attention attention so hmm what
what does this mean exactly I should do
this here maybe
now 96 Quincy 6 is really okay yeah
threatening mate and to winning not how
am I not winning now Queenie for or what
he could play Queenie for I think white
resigns okay so I irritated him with my
lucky play but maybe Queenie for was
possible I wasn't sure I thought I can
take but I wasn't sure about this
position here hmm the night still is a
bit stranded and I have this move yeah
the computer likes black a lot but it's
not not easy at all it looks very very
shaky okay the computer does not find
anything so it is probably simply good
for black but how it weird yeah he just
needs to retreat and then we we play on
like I know this one maybe this idea
it's an active position black can play
on the F file I think F takes G is just
much more interesting than age takes
maybe it's even the bottoms it opens up
this diagonal and he sometimes has
problems with dynamic player miam amen i
recognized as an earlier games okay
thanks for watching this short game